LET'S GO FELLOWS.
>> PREDATORS AND VANCOUVER WENT
HEAD-TO-HEAD IN BRITISH COLOMBI
THE STICK GOES
AND THIS PLAYER OUT OF THE
HOW DID THAT NOT GO IN?
A SHORT LIST OF GUYS THAT HAVE
REDICK HAD A
TRYING TO GET A QUICK LINE
CHANGE. DOTS ON THE
FOUR CORNERS OF DEMKO.
KEPT IN
>> FOR A MINUTE THOUGHT
JOSI IN THE MIDDLE.
WORKS IT
DUCHENNE.
STOPPED BY  AND THE FIRST BREAK-
IN ON THE COVID LIST.
FIRE GOALS.
>> ALMOST THE SAME SPOTATTACK.
NICE PLAY BY JOHANSSON. WILL HA
EASIER BABIG MAN.
MYERS CUTS THROUGH THE NET. UP.
DROP TO HUGHES.
MILLER TOMASINO STOPPED
JOSI AND A CARRIER DOING
YEOMAN'S WORK.
CLOSE TO NINE MINUTES . DEFLECT
WIDE, NO RIGHT BEHIND OF THE
SHOT BLOCK. . LFWAY
BETWEEN THE SHOT AND THE BALL.
THAT WILL LEAVE A MARK.
>> Chris: THISIS
OF
MINUTES.
TRYING TO MA.
A CHANCE TOTO
JUST MISS.
ES DAVID RITTICH . THE
GET IT TO COLEMAN.